i'll go on a bit of a summer break you
might have noticed that
the frequency of videos especially paper
discussion videos
has been going down a little bit that's
because i've been uh
preparing to summer up a bit and
uh we're really close to 100k
subscribers thank you everyone who's
already here if you're not subscribed
subscribe i hope we can do a sort of
proper
uh channel recap review celebration
once this happens so yeah i'm gonna make
this really short
i'll be gone for a bit a few videos in
the pipeline uh not
too much though we'll see if there's any
any surprise or something like this
so this means i won't be checking
twitter
linkedin etc as much if you really need
to catch me during this time you'll
probably
find me still every now and then
checking the discord community if you're
not a member yet
it's a really nice community i
absolutely suggest
you become a member and with that i wish
everybody
a happy and sunny summer bye
you